yeah it actually is always just so
[__] chaotic as well for us because
obviously like the the we can't
experience it in like a normal way
anymore which is kind of like it sucks
um but also I mean ax is as a con is
just I mean a mess I mean it's like from
a viewer perspective I a lot of the time
I feel like it's
you go there to hang out with your
friends and not for like what there is
to actually do there yeah at least
that's how I always did it before at
least
um and and now I guess what we do is we
just promote stuff my Twitter feed that
weekend was just one ad I got to the
point where like I was they would just
send me an ad and normally like when we
get sent an ad like a tweet that we have
to promote they'll be like hey can you
see more natural I was like nope I'm
just gonna tweet whatever you give me
yes because I was like I'm abandoning
all hopes of trying to make this look
like I wrote this this weekend and I was
like there's a few of them where people
were like hey this looks like you didn't
write I'm like I didn't correct
um you know because a lot of the times
the the booths are like hey come come to
a booth and appear here and and whatnot
there's one those guys did I won't name
which one it is because I don't want to
get anyone trouble or me in trouble I
went to this one we were at one of the
booths doing a promotional thing and it
was kind of chaotic and stuff wasn't
going well which is all of them
um and this guy walks in
this guy who walks into the booth I'm
chilling he's like who's in charge here
and I was like I don't know I'm just
chilling yeah and he's like is it that
woman over there I was like yeah it's my
boss and he goes he just throws his
business card at me he's like I'll deal
with this what the [__] who are you
gives me a card it's like CEO of
marketing I was like who the [__] what
an [__] just comes in like gives us
like this gives me his card like like
he's looking this way he's like I'll
I'll handle this
like a [__] Johnny Bravo ass
character and I was like this guy must
think he's so such hot [__] and I'm like
I don't give a [__] I'm I'm here to just
chill Jesus yeah I mean most of the time
was just spent this time we didn't did
you have time to walk the convention a
little bit very very very little amount
yeah most of my time will spend at the
booth uh working behind it uh or just
like chilling out behind it or just like
different Booth appearances there was
there was this one moment that was funny
when like the booth was being built
and it was like Day Zero or something
and uh we're like I was sitting down uh
my editor Alan who I brought with me
like to help like build the set
everything he was helping out as well
and we were like sitting down having our
first like meeting for the day uh so
it's like me mailing is like some other
Geeks Plus members and then uh some of
the staff members come up to our booth
they go up to our like stand-ins and I'm
like oh my God the boys are here I don't
believe it and I'm like sitting right
next to it and they just walked past me
and go to like the stand what happened a
lot actually I'd be like oh hi guys
Hi
and then and it was literally like the
[__] meme where you're just standing
in the corner like they don't know I'm
gone they don't know I'm the real gun
right here
tested that out by like replacing your
cardboard cutout and just standing in
his place and see if like anyone would
notice
[Music]
yeah but I mean you know X was a lot of
fun I guess I'll try and be there next
time all right Joey we will miss we're
missing the boy man I feel bad because
it's such a big con and obviously well
what was I was being too popular uh
people asking for pictures and we just
can't take pictures because if we do it
just causes like a mess and people start
lining up and grouping uh and it's like
I feel sad because I'm like man I want
to take pictures of everyone but
obviously I [__] can't
um but I guess also people sometimes
just ask for pictures and they have no
idea who you are because they just see
that everyone else's pictures I hate
that so much
no I love that [__] no because you're
like what's your one time on stream at
ax like last time I was like oh yeah
he's like I'm a big fan of his favorite
video he's like oh when you spent 24
hours in a manga Cafe I was like that's
I got this on camera I was like that's
that's Joey
I think confusing me and God I don't
know how they confuse you and I
I do nothing alike that's just a
different ethnicity because I wish there
was like a yeah I know some people will
use codes and they're like they say a
code word and it's like oh okay okay
you're cool yeah but yeah I just yeah
it's kind of yeah it's whatever uh but
we did a we did a panel that didn't get
uh broadcast we did the panel for
katakawa yeah and that was fun but that
was like very I mean that was that was
kind of scary because we're like we're
also doing it for all of these anime
companies and they're trusting us to
it's just like having a piece yeah yeah
and like you know maybe there's a show
that is popular and people get super
excited for and there's some shows
people don't know or maybe the shows
that like aren't as popular and
sometimes you're like okay well you want
to make sure that there's an equal level
of hype for all of them yeah yeah it was
great seeing Connor have to pretend to
care about isakai for like an hour and a
half well that was I was like this is
easy I liked it I liked it because you
know we all have our own yeah I hope
they don't watch this we have our own
personal preference and I've obviously
not known for liking
a very strong words and then I'd read
the thing and I you know because God had
obviously because God has knows the
anime A lot better than me I I was kind
of reading out and doing all the
transitional stuff yeah and I was like
all right so next up we have an isakai
and I was like okay first time nice and
it's like fourth one and I'm like all
right another isakai gone gonna tell me
about what this one is and I'm gonna be
like let me tell you how this easy guy
stands out from the rest of the Easter
guy I mean I I do that because I [__]
love it anyway so this is cool though
for every single one we got to Premiere
an episode of my happy marriage it was
kind of sick actually being like hey
guys we've got a [__] got an episode
of an anime to show you a Premiere I was
like that's so cool oh my God actually
it was funny because uh I really like
when we're on stage I would like really
put mail in on the spot because there
are so there were like some shows like
like happy sugar life and especially
like my happy marriage uh beautiful
there's like a beautiful man I actually
thought my happy marriage was happy
sugar life I was like wait is this
actually come out yeah like you know a
bit of a dominant energy kind of like oh
okay kind of like brooding yeah
and I'm like this is like how can I how
can I describe this man this is the kind
of anime character that gets malin's
hands to sweat and then the first thing
that Maiden says to me when she comes
off when I come off stage is she was
like you're right my hands were actually
sweating during that trailer
oh my God and I I don't I don't want to
like so there was the premiere of the
first episode of Happy sugar life um
he's like he's like sure on Netflix
it's a show on Netflix
um honestly like generally speaking uh
sponsorship and everything [__]
decided Well he would have to say
anything nice about it was on the panel
we just had to yeah as a as an anime fan
uh generally I think one of the best new
shows there in the season uh is by
kinnamon Citrus and everything like that
uh that was tough I was reading some of
these Studio names and I was like [__] I
hope I said that right because we didn't
get to see anything about this panel
until yeah
yeah but uh so the main character uh is
kind of like this very you know quiet
Reserve typical like Japanese girl and
the whole premise of the show is that it
she it's kind of like she has someone
she's in love with but
she has a bully right and this bully is
like a sassy blonde anime character and
okay it's like I in my mind I was like
everyone in the audience is going to be
like oh it's just like Sydney like you
know because that's what happens in like
every one of my in like every one of my
streams uh every time there's a blonde
Army character it's Sydney yeah and then
because everybody knows Sydney's the
only blonde woman alive exactly exactly
so the blonde character is uh like kind
of like a bully to this like mean girl
okay and so the main girl has a guy that
she's in love with I'm only spawning
episode one by the way yeah uh um the
mango only has like has a guy that she's
in love with and of course you know
spice it up it turns out that the guy is
going to get married to her bully okay
and so
and so we finally so we're I'm watching
this backstage with Sydney uh and then
so we find out some of the girls
backstory and it's like a sad like
really sad backstory uh like her
mother's Dead uh and when
when the scene of like her backstory
comes up it smells me this really like
sad scene that just shows her mother
dying oh [__] that just shows her
mother's like her mother is dead yeah
Cindy just burst out laughing and I'm
like God [__] damn it Sydney you do
not have to eat like she she was like I
was like oh the [__] comments are
right like every blonde anime character
that's sassy and Bullies is just Sydney
because she the the mother is dying and
Cindy's just like burst out laughing and
like one of our staff members were just
it was just literally like the Robert de
niro-like moment and the joke because
like really her mother's dead and you're
laughing
meanwhile I was eating chicken tenders
meanwhile Connor was eating chicken
tenders behind the scenes ah but
honestly yeah it was a great experience
and it was honestly great seeing like
just an anime Premiere with a lot of
other people it was uh one of the most
hypers moments was actually when we
showed the re-zero trailer oh my God
everyone was like screaming non-stop
it's pretty cool yeah and I was like
wait a minute this could actually be the
be pretty hard maybe it's pretty hard
watching anime with like other people
yeah other people's reaction right right
yeah it is hype it is I would love to
see more of it watching just an anime
with a crowd would be great yeah but
there was there's one moment where like
there's a character with big boobs and
everyone started cheering
I was like you [__] guys what's wrong
with you guys yeah everyone have we not
seen enough everyone started cheering
and I was just like because at the point
I was like John didn't know why they
were cheering I was like looking at the
notes I was like is there like something
that just got announced or something
because I was like trying to make sure
that the next segment was going to go
smoothly so I was like is there a big
name attachments because everyone just
started cheering and then I looked
behind me and then I saw the post of
like like a girl with massive tits and I
was like oh okay okay now I get it I was
the one
yeah I was the one operating the clicker
so I knew why they were cheering because
I I knew the slide that it went to yeah
and then I was like I was hoping that it
would just kind of we just go we can
ignore it and then of course it came
back up and I started cheering again and
I was like God damn it yeah this is why
we can't this is why no one thinks that
we're good members of society
uh yeah and that was fun and then uh we
had that that was the whole thing and
yeah I did my panel with mouse as well
that was streamed dude the line was
[__] for that yeah yeah the line went
like all the way into the hotel to the
fourth floor went out to the hotel all
the way back to the entrance back out do
you know where this the microphone you
know the JW Marriott Hotel yeah so that
and then there's that Starbucks and
there's a Microsoft Arena yeah the line
came all the way out all the way around
the Microsoft Arena to the start of it
and just for this panel how many people
fit in no no dude by the time like they
were all lining up it was already full
okay I guess people didn't know that so
it was it was like a two two thousand
two thousand two thousand room I wasn't
yeah it was like two thousand yeah yeah
uh because I think main stage
Main Events was reserved for like
industry stuff yeah yeah
um or whatever it was so they were like
no no no main event yeah and that was
crazy that was a lot of fun it's always
weird having to interact with the screen
and the delay and stuff but it's a lot
of fun and it got streams so you can go
and check it out there's collapse online
as well
um yeah I mean right now it just seems
like Anime Expo has just basically just
become the E3 of anime if E3 was like
still a thing because every time I go
there like so many exciting anime
announcements get like released during
like ax it's actually insane yeah it's
actually insane like as an anime fan I
love ax just because I know this is
where all like the hottest news is gonna
like get released about some exciting
projects we could go like you know like
out of [__] nowhere DC is uh
collaborating with Studio wit dude oh
yeah a Suicide Squad isakai where the
[__] did this come from I pretty I
called this on the podcast I said they
could just they're just gonna e-sik how
[__] that we've had before I literally
said play the clip there's a short
someone found it and they because I
didn't even know I said this someone
sent it to me like you called it I said
that they're just gonna isakai shows
that already existed yeah and they're
[__] doing it yeah I said they would
do this I think I saw that announcement
on Twitter like or rumors about it a few
weeks ago but I was like nah that can't
be real right that sounds ridiculous
first of all who cares because black
Butler's coming back that's all the
money oh yeah Black Butler you don't
sound like as excited besides I mean
it's it's blackball as you see they made
him in like a soft boy now yeah what the
[__] why I'm not excited why is he like
a soft boy he looks like he spends too
much time on VR chat now
oh yes I feel like trigger are are like
very very good when it's like
boobs
okay you know what I'm not gonna take
the credit for it but I was when I
interviewed the co-founder of trigger I
did ask for a season two of painting
okay the guy said that they're at the
build meeting
me but uh I was the first one they're
like they're like they're like they're
like we can't do it guys it doesn't make
any sense the anime man said
he wanted it I wanted it don't show my
shorts I wanted it and he was like We'll
think about it and then he delivers so
thank you very much yeah
thank you so much Joey for um
stocking you are clearly it is good it's
all used
thank you Joey Joey
[Music]
I'll give you a suggestion bring one
punch man back
I mean like I'll think about it